n 60 médecins impuissants et des noms
pour la succession
c'est qu'un une percée de la technique
française dans la grande muraille
londres une vente historique celle de la
collection personnelle de coco chanel
bonsoir on tire en ce moment dans les
rues de téhéran la capitale de l'iran
alors que le calme était revenu ce matin
une nouvelle manifestation est en train
de se dérouler déjà dans l'après midi
hier puis dans la soirée malgré le
couvre-feu
l'armée avait riposté en tirant à l'armé
automatique pour intimider les
manifestants
le bilan de ces nouveaux troubles qui
marque le début de la période de deuil
religieux des musulmans chiites
le bilan serait selon l'opposition de 70
morts et de près de 2000 blessés
téhéran lire après midi
errant période de moharram ce day qui
commémore le martyre du petit fils de
bao m usain supplicié est mort de soi
qui lui envieraient 520 dans le désert
de kerbala
terran qui sort des drapeaux noirs pour
bien montrer que cette année la ferveur
religieuse ira de pair avec la
contestation politique
et les manifestations commencent d'abord
dans le calme avec des slogans
anti-gouvernementaux on acclame aussi le
nom de l'ayatollah khomeiny qui vient de
demander aux soldats de déserté leurs
casernes et aux grévistes de l'industrie
pétrolière de continuer leur mouvement
mais déjà tout le monde s'attend au pire
la loi martiale qui est toujours en
vigueur à téhéran tout rassemblement de
plus de trois personnes est interdit et
l'armée l'armée qui veille à tous les
points stratégiques de la ville ne
restera pas indifférente
cela personne ne ligne
très vite les premiers coups de feu sont
perçus les soldats tirent en l'air pour
disperser les manifestants mais au fil
des minutes les fusils et les
mitrailleuses ou pointer en direction de
la foule
bilan semble 70 morts peut être même
beaucoup plus la manifestation est
terminée mais elle va se reformer
quelques rues plus loin
en attendant une nouvelle fois
l'intervention de l'armée
cela devrait continuer ainsi jusqu'au 12
décembre jour de l'achoura le jour
anniversaire de la mort du martyr neuf
journées très difficiles que s'apprête à
vivre le shah d'iran
l'état de santé du président boumédiène
à aucun moment le président algérien n'a
été placées en état de survie
artificielle a expliqué hier soir
l'agencé de presse algérienne qui ajoute
l'activité du cortex cérébral du chef de
l'état algérien est parfaitement normal
une mise au point qui entend répondre
dit l'agencé aps
à une campagne de presse internationale
tendancieuse fin de citation
pendant cieux ou pas il est vrai que
depuis quelques jours on évoqué le
problème de l'acharnement thérapeutique
qui aurait permis comme pour le général
franco il y a quelques années de
maintenir artificiellement en vie le
président algérien depuis alger
bernard rapp par téléphone
la télé ligne le matin dans les
quotidiens el moudjahid a causé une
certaine surprise parmi les observateurs
présents à alger un appel immédiatement
du romain le communiqué apparaît d'abord
comme un démenti cinglant vous attire
matière de la presse internationale
acculé les districts et des informations
tendancieuses quant à l'état de santé de
voirie boumédiène de l'information
qualifiée de mensongère pour les
familles il permet en outre aux
autorités algériennes de répondre au
voeu de la population c'est réclame
depuis quelques semaines d'être informés
que fondaient la maladie de centre les
enfants est essentiellement sur la
démence aux déclarations pour parfaire
ses fesses dans le professeur saïd
namouh non plus des départs de plusieurs
spécialistes et pas seulement les normes
nous y aurait considéré que leur
présence et c'est même le 10 mai du
sillage on la trouve dans ce soir une
nouvelle fois en situation d'attenté et
la mention faite dans les communiqués
une pacifiste et d'amélioration de
l'état de houari boumédiène donne à
penser que cette attente pourrait être
longue
le temps voilà que régler l'automne à
pékin pour monsieur jean françois deniau
le ministre français du commerce
extérieur et peut-être demain matin la
signature d'un contrat historique
historique parce que ce sera le premier
contrat conclu par la chine avec un pays
occidental après celui passé avec le
japon je dis peut-être car dans les
négociations il ya encore quelques
points de détails à régler entre experts
français et experts chinois
à tel point que monsieur deniau a
préféré écourter son séjour dans la
province du sud ouest de la chine pour
rentrer à pékin ce soir afin de mieux
suivre les dernières discussions avec
son dazibao cette affiche qui l'a montré
à son homologue chinois et qui réclamait
des contrats pour la france monsieur
deniau a bien fait rire ses
interlocuteurs chinois cette semaine
cette fois on est passé aux choses
sérieuses à pékin philippe sassier notre
envoyé spécial a pu s'en rendre compte
en visitant l'exposition française
l'exposition française des techniques de
gaz pétrole et pétrochimie qui vient de
s'ouvrir à pékin se veut la vitrine de
la technologie française
du côté chinois cette exposition
signifie que le mot d'ordre des années
60 ne comptons que sur nos propres
forces est actuellement plus de mise
cela signifie il faut faire appel aux
techniques le matériel venu de
l'étranger pour nous développer
les actuels dirigeants de la chine ont
décidé de leur de faire de leur pays une
grande puissance pétrolière d'ici à la
fin du siècle une puissance susceptible
de réaliser même avec les états unis sur
le plan pétrolier alors cela signifie
bien sûr des investissements énormes
et puis aussi probablement des débouchés
pour beaucoup d'entreprises françaises
les ambitions économiques industrielles
de la chine sont peut-être le signe le
plus concret est le plus visible des
modifications apportées par le régime
actuel
la france était le quatrième fournisseur
de la chine
elle est tombée au 13e rang l'année
dernière sur ce marché de 900 millions
de personnes elle peut quand même
espérer retrouver une meilleure place ça
correspond d'ailleurs pas du tout à la
place qu'à la france dans le monde du
point de vue du commerce externe nous
sommes le quatrième exportateur mondial
alors il faut retrouver un an normal et
nous devons parfaitement y arriver quel
genre de produit pouvons nous vendre aux
chinois et où c'est tous les produits
avec une technique
important de moderne des chinois
souhaite développer nos échanges leurs
échanges avec nous dans ces domaines là
comme par exemple bien tous les produits
qui relèvent de cette exposition sur le
pétrole le gaz et la pétrochimie
c'est à dire les matériels et techniques
les installations qui leur permettront
de développer leur production de pétrole
je crois qu'il ya des possibilités assez
considérable mais aussi dans le domaine
de l'énergie hydroélectrique de la
sidérurgie dans tous les domaines de
l'activité économique et industriel
moderne mais je pense aussi que nous
pouvons leur vendre des produits
agricoles et j'ai une promesse des
chinois d'acheter du vin français et
nous que pouvons-nous le racheter alors
nous pouvons le racheter pour le moment
des quantités très limitées de produits
traditionnels achetons en chine qui sont
des produits agricoles et quelques
produits spécialisés chinois
la vraie possibilité de développement de
nos importations en provenance de chine
cesse il y as développement des
productions de matières premières dont
nous avons besoin de toute façon c'est à
dire le pétrole et le charbon
et c'est pour ça qu'il est très
important d'être dans ces secteurs de
mise en valeur de la chine en asie
toujours le problème des réfugiés
vietnamiens devant l'ampleur de la
tragédie a dit cours de valdaï le
secrétaire général des nations unies
j'en appelle à tous les gouvernements
pour leur porter assistance
après la france les états unis le canada
et la belgique l'allemagne fédérale a
accueilli ce matin à hanovre 163
passagers du à hong kong
et puis le gouvernement malaisien s'est
enfin décidé à laisser descendre de leur
misérable bateau les derniers réfugiés
vietnamiens qui se trouvaient encore à
bord du ring
le pape jean paul ii a révélé ce matin
qu'il était intervenu auprès des nations
unies en faveur de s'y réfugier
serge me serais
jean paul ii est descendu cet après midi
la garde at elle à un des quartiers
pauvres de rome
on a pu mesurer à cette occasion combien
était grande la popularité du pape le
saint père a déclaré être intervenu
auprès des nations unies en faveur des
réfugiés vietnamiens il a demandé aux
fidèles réunis aujourd'hui de prier pour
ceux qui souffrent parce qu'ils ne
trouvent pas un accueil empreint
d'humanité 163 passagers du ring
viennent d'arriver à hanovre pour eux le
cauchemar est terminé l'allemagne va
recevoir deux mille six cents réfugiés
la province de basse saxe accueillera un
millier de personnes dont 650 passagers
du raï rock
pendant ce temps au large des côtes de
malaisie d'autres réfugiés sont foulés
fou périssent toyer 43 morts 100
disparus aujourd'hui demain soir dans
question de temps vous pourrez voir le
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux en
malaisie
une enquête de jacques à bouchard ainsi
qu'une interview de l'ambassadeur du
vietnam en france monsieur ban soon
question de temps donc demain 21h30 sur
antenne 2 et puis dans l'actualité de
demain lundi il y a le début du conseil
européen de bruxelles c'est à dire la
réunion au sommet des neuf chefs d'état
et de gouvernement sans se tromper on
peut dire dès maintenant que ce conseil
européen risque de prendre une décision
qui sera de loin la plus importante pour
l'europe des neuf depuis l'entrée de la
grande-bretagne dans la communauté en
je veux parler de la création du système
monétaire européen
l'objectif essentiel de ce système
monétaire stabilisé entre elles les
monnaies des neuf pays européens qui ont
été quelque peu secoué ces derniers
temps par les mouvements d'ascenseur du
dollar maurice werther il est temps de
remettre un peu d'ordre dans le système
monétaire des neuf des huit pour
commencer si l'angleterre ne s'y joint
pas tout de suite
on en est arrivé à un point où les
fondements mêmes du marché commun les
bus essentiel de la communauté sont
menacés un exemple la politique agricole
commune à cause des fluctuations des
monnaies on a été conduit peu à peu à
reconstruire de véritables barrières
douanières devant les produits agricoles
alors que le premier objectif du marché
commun est justement de supprimer les
barrières douanières
c'est une nouvelle barrière sont
constitués par ce qu'on appelle les
tant compensatoires monétaire des sortes
de taxes dont le but et d'égaliser d'une
certaine façon les monnaies fortes et
les monnaies faibles expédiant
provisoire en 1969 c'est devenu un
système permanent généralisée et absurde
donc il faut d'abord stabiliser les
menait ensuite peu à peu
supprimer ces montants compensatoires
donc c'est le système monétaire européen
je le disais et ses conséquences sur la
politique agricole qui formeront le gros
morceau du conseil européen de demain
on parlera aussi d'autres choses du
conseil des sages
la prochaine édition de la grèce du
portugal et de l'espagne d'affaires
sociales telles que le chômage des
jeunes dans les pays les communautés
on le dit à chaque fois mais cette fois
ci c'est particulièrement vrai la
rencontre de bruxelles devrait marquer
une date importante dans l'histoire de
la communauté européenne
surtout parce que si ça ne marche pas le
marché commun aura beaucoup de mal à ne
pas dégénérer peu à peu en une vague
associations de libre échange les
suisses ont dit non aujourd'hui à la
création d'une police fédérale de
sécurité un référendum avait été
organisée pour proposer la création de
deux corps de police l'un antiterroriste
l'autre anti émeutes
le tout placé sous l'autorité du
gouvernement fédéral alors
qu'actuellement le maintien d'ordre
dépens des seules autorités locales bien
les suisses ont dit non aujourd'hui à
ces propositions référendum encore mais
en espagne cette fois mercredi prochain
les espagnols se rendront aux urnes pour
donner leur avis sur le projet de
nouvelle constitution
à trois jours du scrutin il faut bien
reconnaître que la campagne électorale a
été bien monotone en espagne il semble
bien que ce référendum est moins
intéressé les espagnols que les
élections générales d'il ya un an
bruno alba notre correspondant permanent
en espagne fait le poids face de vichy
anglais biya de la constitucion
référendum échéance 6 décembre pour
assurer le succès de la nouvelle
constitution
les partis et le gouvernement mobilise
mais alors que d'habitude dans une
consultation électorale de ce genre les
murs des villes se couvre de wii ou de
nom cette fois ci à madrid comme dans
toute l'espagne
c'est un seul mot qui revient tout au
long des rues c'est le mans voter car
cette fois ci en espagne ce n'est pas
tant l'oignon aux nouvelles institutions
espagnoles qu'il s'agit de madre mais
beaucoup plus l'abstention
les spécialistes électoraux ont investi
plus de 100 millions de francs dans la
publicité pour le référendum
un dixième seulement de cette somme est
dépensée en faveur du oui proprement dit
et si le gouvernement et les états
majors politiques consacrent toute leur
force appelé les espagnols à voter c'est
bien que leur souci est de voir monter
au plus haut le chiffre de participation
électorale pour valoriser la nouvelle
constitution
car bien que tous les espagnols de plus
de 18 ans peut appeler à voter les
électeurs semblent nettement moins
passionné par l'événement qu'ils ne le
furent il y a un an pour les élections
générales
je crois que la principale vers des
politiciens actuels et a été donnée
n'est pas content et suffisamment sur le
sur le type l'espagnol l'espagnol a été
à un certain moment préparé peut
participer et il est un peu déçu parce
que on n'a pas beaucoup compter sur lui
et je le monde après simple pour le
moment d les dépossessions son vote
quant au moment du référendum sans
évoquer ce problème de la nouvelle
constitution georges marchais a
réaffirmé hier soir à perpignan au terme
de sa visite en languedoc-roussillon qui
ne souhaitait pas voir entrer l'espagne
dans le marché commun et que le parti
communiste était hostile à
l'élargissement de la communauté
économique européenne
pour sa part michel crépeau du mouvement
des radicaux de gauche a rappelé pendant
ce week-end l'attachement de son
mouvement à l'europe
de plus en plus nécessaire at il dit
pour résister à l'influencé américaine
au cours du club de la presse d'europe 1
madame monique pelletier ministre de la
condition féminine indiqué ce soir qu'il
y aurait six femmes parmi les 20
premiers candidats sur la liste de l'udf
aux élections à l'assemblée européenne
la femme et l'europe non plus pour la
politique cette fois mais plutôt pour la
mode ou plutôt pour le style comme le
disait coco chanel il n'y a pas de mode
chanel c'est un style la mode se démode
le style jamais c'est une phrase de
vocaux chaney pourquoi est-ce que je
vous parle de coco chanel et bien tout
simplement parce que hier soir à londres
on a vendu aux enchères chez christie's
la collection personnelle de la grande
couturière française décédée en 1971 un
défilé de mannequins un peu nostalgique
casque vie pour une première pour cette
vente aux enchères de tailleur et bijoux
ayant appartenu à coco chanel ans
n'avait pas fait les choses à moitié il
y à un mois précise une des plus
somptueux sac de vente de grande
bretagne et sans doute du monde avait
invité la presse avec champagne
mannequin et tout le falbala pour
présenter robes manteaux bijoux et sacs
en tout 120 pièces ayant été dessinés
porter paraît-il par la célèbre mode
liste des années 30 puis cinq ans
nîmes marx in type soc par exemple ce
manteau et jupes de tweed confectionner
assure la présentatrice par coco chanel
est porté par elle lors d'une visite
anémone marcus au texas en 1954 quelques
soucieux se sont inquiétés de savoir si
ses vêtements avaient réellement été
porté par coco chanel la couturière
ayant l'habitude de déclarer qu'elle
n'avait en tout et pour tout que trois
tailleur un noir un blanc et un bleu
marine et qu'elle est usée jusqu'à la
corde lesquelles dès lors de ses
quelques 35 pièces étaient les plus usés
et avait quelques chances d'avoir
réellement appartenu à mademoiselle enel
et ont pas payé très cher une robe
portée par dieu sait qui que les
scrupuleux bas et leur réticence de
toute façon tout cela était fort beau en
particulier cet ensemble boutonnet porté
par coco chanel en suisse et en italie
le jour d'une première d'un film de
visconti tant de précision et fasse le
nous l'ensemble était vendu par liane
brune bac d'abord attaché de presse puis
ami intime de coco chanel et qui avait
gardé tous ses trésors d'élégance depuis
sept ans depuis la mort de la grande
couturière il n'y a pas de mode chanel
c'est un style la mode se démode le
style jamais disait mademoiselle chanel
tant mieux pour li yang run bike qui
vendait les robes se sont aujourd'hui
rallonger est sans wc vrai qu'on peut
mettre un channel et sortir il y aura
des clients 300 s'était fait inscrire
pour le jour de la vente pour acheter ce
bout d'histoire de la mode féminine
l'histoire en fait de la libération de
la femme chanel ayant été la première
dans les années 20 à jeter crinolines et
baleines effet dit on sortir la femme de
ses corsets
mais pourquoi vendre cette collection
est d'abord à qui appartient tel
on fait à moi
je pense qu'elle appartiendra j'espère
il appartient à l'histoire elle
appartient
j'aimerais qu'elle a
s'en aillent dans les musées et des
collectionneurs pour pouvoir
continuer d'exister et pourquoi la
vendée vous précisément
je pense que
on ne va pas garder ça enfermé dans une
armoire
vous avez dit d'ailleurs qu'il fallait
pas que cette collection restent dans
les tiroirs où les armoires mais elle va
partir aux etats-unis dans les tiroirs
où les armoiries samu rien aux états
unis en france ou aux états unis en
france en angleterre en allemagne et 1
but partout
non pas sur celles ayant des musées et
tout le monde pour aller la nuit pour
tout le monde pour aller la voir quel
genre de musée peut être intéressé par
coco chanel ou avoir l'argent les musées
son étal c'est effectivement hier soir
un musée qui emportera la plus belle
pièce vendue 20 mille francs au musée
d'oslo et la collection va disparaître
pour 650 mille francs trois musées
achèteront deux anglais dont le victoria
and albert museum et un norvégien le
reste est allé à de riches américains ou
anglais
l'essentiel des robes s'étant vendu et
aux environs de 10 mille francs
c'est que l'achat le plus sympathique
lui de cette jeune fille elle travaille
chez christie's et s'est offert le
channel pour 5000 francs et le portant à
madame vincent auriol a été hospitalisé
cet après midi la veuve de l'ancien
président de la république a été victime
d'un malaise
elle est âgée de 83 ans les pirates de
la route près de pomponne en
seine-et-marne la nuit dernière un
automobiliste qui roulait sur la
nationale 34 a été coincé sur le bas
côté de la route par une 504 où il a
fait une queue de poisson quatre hommes
sont descendus ils ont assommé le
chauffeur et l'ont dévalisée avant de
s'enfuir
et puis un trésor sous un arbre en
charente-maritime fables de la fontaine
version à 78 un cultivateur de saint
mandé sur brédoire monsieur guillaume un
rachète un arbre sous les racines il y
avait un trésor 60 pièces d'or datant du
xvième siècle frappé à l'éffigie de
philippe ii d'espagne
un collectionneur a offert à monsieur
guillaume déjà 5 millions de centimes
il a refusé il préfère les mettre aux
enchères en sport je vous rappelle
simplement les principaux résultats de
la journée à savoir qu'en rugby à
bucarest la france a battu la roumanie 9
assists petite victoire en football il y
avait cinq matches et après midi en
première division les voici voici les
résultats n'ont pas gagné à l'extérieur
4 1
et lyon fait match nul 2-2 paris
football club et nancy 1 partout
saint-etienne a battu valenciennes 5 0
et angers a battu sochaux 3 à 2 en tête
du championnat de france il ya toujours
strasbourg bien sûr et puis dans la
transatlantique française en solitaire
toujours l'inquiétude pour alain colas
dont on n'a aucune nouvelle ni par les
radioamateurs ni à contribution cette
semaine ni par les recherches de la
marine nationale
à l'arrivée en guadeloupe on commence
maintenant à envisager toutes les
hypothèses pierre salviac notre
correspondant notre envoyé spécial plus
tôt a rencontré michel malinovski le
deuxième de cette course du rhum et lui
a demandé si les navigateurs prenait
bien toutes les précautions nécessaires
pour assurer leur sécurité pendant la
course et s'il mettait par exemple leur
harnais de sécurité
il faut d'abord bien connaissant bateaux
passant jusqu'où on peut aller colas je
pense que là ils le savaient puisqu'il a
fait le tour du monde avec ce bateau il
a fait un vrai course exceptionnelle si
on va trop loin
c'est là où les risques augmentent de
façon extraordinaire mais ça je lui fais
confiance pour qu'il n'ait pas été trop
loin ou alors il a eu un accident
physique il n'a pas pu maîtriser son
bateau un bon moment mais c'est moi je
n'aime pas tellement faire de ce genre
de suppositions qui sont assez gratuite
finalement un solitaire qui tombe à
l'eau il est toujours soir de sécurité
pour le moment
non vous savez moi j'ai pensé à ça
souvent mais le harnais que je les ai
mis une fois sur 25 jours peut-être
parce que vraiment je me suis dit là si
je vais à la vente et qu'il y avait plus
d'un mètre
dos au sud du pont par moment j'ai même
avec musculairement je n'avais même pas
la force de me retenir face à la mer
donc là j'avais mis mon harnais mais la
plupart du temps ne met pas parce que
c'est une gêne on se déplace pas assez
vite on a cette ficelle qui vous suit
sans arrêt et qui vous c'est un handicap
mais c'est efficace le harnais si vous
tombez à nouveau en solitaire
oui et non parce que d'abord j'en ai vu
plusieurs classes et les jeunes
malheureusement et deuxièmement si vous
passez par dessus bord et que le bateau
quand ils vont le votre vote reboot fait
un mètre de m ou 3 mètres
si le passé par dessus bord vous êtes
dans l'eau le pont se trouve à un mètre
au dessus de vous et compte tenu de la
vitesse du bateau et neuf fois sur dix
on n'avait pas la force de remonter à
bord tout seul il faut que l'on va tout
s'arrête pour que vous puissiez remonter
parce que vous êtes pris par la force de
l'eau comme en europe où céline voilà
hélas là c'est bien
ou une vague que vous re remettre sur le
pont du bateau
ou alors vous pouvez vous noyer comme ça
on la traîne derrière le bateau il est
un tiercé aujourd'hui à auteuil dans la
5e course c'est will fils le 2 qui a
gagné devant romarin le 6 et rsiq le cap
la combinaison gagnante et donc 2 6 4
voici sur un panneau les rapports de ce
tiercé pour 5 francs de 6,4 dans l'ordre
4767 france dans un ordre différent
424 france le 6 4
voilà ils ont passé le poteau pour une
page et spectacles maintenant pour
terminer ce journal avec tout d'abord le
théâtre roger planchon et le tnp de
villeurbanne de villeurbanne ont pris
leurs quartiers d'hiver à nanterre dans
la banlieue parisienne au programme il y
a deux pièces de shakespeare
antoine et cléopâtre diversement
accueilli par la critique
puis il ya périclès en revanche
unanimement encensé périclès c'est
claude rich un comédien dont on parle
assez peu mais dont le talent est
remarquable et dont la carrière est
éloquente claude rich préfère se tenir à
l'écart de l'agitation du show business
et du spectacle vous allez comprendre
pourquoi en regardant ce reportage de
georges b to c d
hélas hélas hélas la mère m'a roulé sur
les rochers un roulé de rivage en rivage
nommé laissant de souffle que pour
augurer ma mort imminente pouvoir
répéter ses textes à pleine voix
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
claude rich habite la campagne mais ce
n'est pas la seule sa maison c'est sa
fourmilière et 10 ans magazine tous y
compris c'est que je suis retrouvé celle
à qui datent du conservatoire je
souhaiterais satin et mon premier film
ça a été les grandes manoeuvres de rené
clair avec brigitte bardot et catherine
oger aussitôt théâtre de la pièce que
j'ai préféré de toutes celles que j'ai
joué une victoire deux enfants pouvoir a
vécu ta té guerre bernard noël puis a eu
l'organisation
et puis il ya eu pour assassin et puis
il ya ma tempe et reckless
il martèle t elle
nous révélerons comme ans est morte vite
à nouveau je ne devrais noble seigneur
mais je m'en prit d'abord parce que dans
ma douleur aussi montrera tout ce qu'on
a trouvé avec el ayeb ce que vous devez
savoir salut madame je vous connais pas
je te laisse souvent nommé celui à qui
fuit en tire qu'avait confirmée atteint
cp et les gars nice en baisse le charter
assez
il me tarde à prendre par quels moyens
tu fus rendu à la vie et qui outre les
dieux pour ce grand miracle je dois
remercier
j'aime profondément ma maison parce que
j'y ai apporté tout de moi je vous dis
mes fantasmes et envie j'aime la maison
mais j'aime surtout le jardin
l'environnement et j'aime la nature
j'aime l'odeur de saison j'aime l'odeur
de la terre
j'aime ma maison un peu comme demander
1000 femmes c'est-à-dire par ces odeurs
par ces bruits forcé
sa chaleur par sa lumière
ce qui est difficile dans un avis d'un
comedia c'est de meubler les moments où
il joue pas alors j'écris parce qu'on
peut dire des choses différentes
et puis une maison c'est fait pour
écrire un endroit merveilleux pour pour
partir ailleurs
quand on est bien à la journée à travers
l'image que vous donnez de vous dans les
films dans les pièces de théâtre on a
l'impression d'un rêveur devenir réelle
d'un fou d'un pervers candide est ce que
vous vous reconnaissez dans ce portrait
mou
oui de quelqu'un qui se moque un peu les
choses aussi oui je n'aime pas qu'on se
prenne au sérieux d'un fou c'est parce
que je n'aime pas les gens raisonnables
d'un rêveur parce que j'ai toujours que
j'ai il n'aime pas tellement la vie
réelle et que j'ai mis à rêver je suis
plus touchées les choses passées que des
choses présentes mais je suis aussi
tourné vers l'avenir
voilà ce sera le point final ce journal
pour laisser la place à l'événement ce
soir sur antenne 2 à savoir simon
boccanegra l'opéra de verdi vous
retrouverez pierre-alain à 22h55 très
belle soirée